[Música]
Hola hoy en sciencelich que se vería al
caer en un agujero negro
un agujero negro es una región esférica
del universo una especie de burbujas
espacio temporal que tiene una gravedad
extrema esta burbuja atrae los objetos
hacia su centro como si tirara del
tejido del espacio tal y como lo hace
una estrella o un planeta la superficie
de la burbuja se denomina el Horizonte
del agujero negro divide el universo en
dos regiones el exterior y la parte
inferior por debajo del horizonte el
tejido del universo está siendo
arrastrado tan rápido que nada ni
siquiera la luz puede escapar
nuestro universo contiene una multitud
de agujeros negros están muy lejos y no
suponen ningún peligro para nosotros
pero por pura curiosidad podemos
preguntarnos qué veríamos si cayéramos
en uno de ellos responder a esta
pregunta nos permitirá entender mejor
algunos de los fenómenos extremos del
universo y rectificar ciertos conceptos
erróneos que circulan sobre este tema
en el corazón de nuestra galaxia la vía
láctea hay un agujero negro supermasivo
llamado Sagitario a Estrella
a bordo de una nave espacial nos
acercamos a una distancia prudente y
saltamos al vacío del espacio aquí
comienza nuestro descenso durará
aproximadamente una hora y será fatal
para nosotros la nave por su parte
permanece inmóvil y nos observa caer
[Música]
incluso antes de empezar a caer tenemos
un problema el agujero negro es
supermasivo con una masa equivalente a
varios millones de veces la del sol
con semejante atracción captura las
Estrellas y la materia que la rodea
formando un grueso disco de plasma que
orbita a su alrededor
este disco gira velocidades vertiginosas
cercanas a la de la luz y pierde energía
por la fricción provocando turbulencias
que lo calientan esto produce entonces
una intensa radiación luz rayos
ultravioletas rayos x y rayos Gamma que
nos ciegan instantáneamente y pueden
quemarnos vivos
[Música]
la materia que puede alcanzar varios
miles de millones de grados también
puede quemarnos al contacto
de momento partiremos de la idea de que
nos hemos puesto un traje extremadamente
resistente que a estas alturas nos
permite sobrevivir y filtrar las
radiaciones nocivas
a pesar de este traje el disco sigue
pareciendo extremadamente brillante es
imposible distinguir cualquier cosa por
lo tanto imaginaremos que nuestro casco
tiene un visor que nos permite atenuar
el brillo del disco para poder observar
sus detalles y las estrellas que se
encuentran en el segundo plano
[Música]
al principio constatamos que el disco es
azul
de todo el espectro electromagnético que
emite nuestro visor deja pasar la luz
visible la que pueden ver nuestros ojos
en esta franja el disco emite más azul
porque este color es más energético es
el mismo mecanismo que da a las
estrellas muy calientes su tono a su
lado
extrañamente un lado del disco se ve más
brillante que el otro
para entenderlo mejor es necesario
observar que la materia gira muy
rápidamente alrededor del agujero negro
así por un lado las ondas de luz se
acumulan las recibimos con más
frecuencia mientras que por el otro lado
la luz se dilata la recibimos con menos
energía
es lo que se llama el efecto Doppler es
el mismo fenómeno que se produce con las
ondas sonoras cuando un vehículo pasa
por delante de nosotros
al mirar el agujero negro la parte
posterior del disco parece estar
distorsionada como si se doblase
alrededor del horizonte formando un
anillo de luz
Esto se debe a la fuerte gravedad del
agujero negro que desvía los rayos de
luz actuando como una lente
gravitacional
al mirar en una dirección podemos ver
objetos que en realidad están situados
en otro lugar
por último las estrellas que se
encuentran en el segundo plano nos
parecen ligeramente azuladas De hecho no
nos damos cuenta pero el agujero negro
distorsiona el tiempo de modo que
nuestro reloj va ligeramente más lento
que el de las estrellas lejanas
respecto a nuestro reloj la luz de las
estrellas parece estar ligeramente
acelerada por lo que parece cambiarse
hacia el azul
[Música]
sorprendentemente Durante los primeros
10 minutos de la caída parece que el
agujero negro se aleja sin embargo cada
vez nos acercamos más a él pero su
imagen parece encogerse poco a poco
imaginemos que lanzamos una pelota a
través de un automóvil la pelota es
lanzada con un ángulo de 90 grados y
atraviesa por completo El automóvil el
pasajero ve como la pelota lo atraviesa
a 90 grados
ahora imaginemos que el automóvil está
en movimiento esta vez el pasajero la ve
llegar de frente en un ángulo más agudo
como el automóvil está en movimiento los
objetos que le llegan parecen venir de
una dirección diferente angostada hacia
el frente
[Música]
en nuestro caso cerca del agujero negro
la situación es la misma y Los Rayos de
Luz cumplen el mismo papel que la bola
recibimos la luz del disco desde una
determinada dirección Pero como nos
movemos hacia el agujero negro Los Rayos
parecen llegar desde una dirección
diferente contraída hacia el frente se
trata del fenómeno de aberración de la
luz
[Música]
después de los primeros 10 minutos
empezamos a caer muy rápido a un 4% de
la velocidad de la luz y a partir de ese
momento el agujero negro empieza a
crecer en nuestro campo de visión
con el transcurso de los minutos nuestra
velocidad aumenta y recibimos la luz
delante de nosotros con una mayor
intensidad mientras que la luz detrás de
nosotros Parece ser cada vez más tenue
se trata de nuevo del efecto Doppler a
medida que caemos hacia el agujero negro
alcanzamos la luz que tenemos delante
mientras que la luz de atrás tiene cada
vez más dificultades para alcanzarnos
si nos damos la vuelta también nos damos
cuenta de que el reloj de la nave que
dejamos atrás nuestro parece ir cada vez
más despacio el efecto es leve pero aún
así es perceptible
esto también se debe al efecto Doppler
si imaginamos que el reloj de la nave
emite una señal por segundo los rayos
tardan cada vez más en llegar a nosotros
y constatamos que el reloj se retrasa
[Música]
los minutos pasan y poco a poco vamos
sobrevolando el disco de agresión
de repente tras 57 minutos de caída el
disco parece desvanecerse
acabamos de alcanzar la distancia a
partir de la cual la materia ya no es
capaz de mantenerse en órbita alrededor
del agujero negro El plasma comienza a
girar muy rápidamente hacia el Horizonte
ahora las cosas se acelerarán cada vez
más
[Música]
Solo dos minutos Después estamos el
doble de cerca del horizonte aquí Toda
la luz procedente al exterior está
destinada a caer en el agujero negro
esto se llama la Esfera de fotones
a esta distancia precisa la luz puede
incluso orbitar alrededor del agujero
negro
a medida que nos acercamos al Horizonte
los pasajeros que han permanecido en la
nave ven como nuestra imagen se
desvanece y se ralentiza gradualmente
hasta congelarse en el Horizonte
la luz que emitimos tiene cada vez más
dificultades para escapar del agujero
negro y se desvanece poco a poco
la nave nunca nos verá cruzar el
horizonte
pero para nosotros Sólo 24 segundos
después de haber cruzado la Esfera de
fotones es el momento de llegar al
Horizonte del agujero negro a partir de
ese punto No será imposible Volver atrás
que observamos al sobrepasar el
horizonte
de manera poco intuitiva no se observa
nada en especial de hecho es muy difícil
saber exactamente en qué momento hemos
sobrepasado el horizonte
[Música]
la luz de las estrellas sigue cayendo
con nosotros
todavía podemos ver la nave que ha
permanecido en órbita y en la que el
reloj Aunque parezca haberse [ __ ]
sigue funcionando
Y todavía podemos ver perfectamente
nuestros cuerpos y en particular
nuestros pies porque aunque la luz sea
llevada hacia el centro del agujero
negro con respecto a nosotros puedes
subir con bastante facilidad y llegar a
nuestros ojos
se trata de un principio fundamental a
escala global el espacio-tiempo está
curvado por el agujero negro y genera
así este Horizonte dentro del cual los
objetos están desconectados de su
exterior pero a escala local el
espacio-tiempo es casi plano y la
curvatura no se siente por lo que todo
se comporta normalmente
[Música]
es más a diferencia de lo que se podría
pensar la imagen del agujero negro no
parece englobarnos en absoluto Aunque
ahora estemos en el agujero negro su
imagen solo ocupa el 15% de nuestro
campo de visión el resto Sigue estando
cubierto de estrellas
una vez más se trata el fenómeno de
aberración de la luz nos movemos ahora
extremadamente rápido de modo que la luz
que llega a nuestros lados parece venir
de enfrente nuestro campo de visión se
contrae frente a nosotros y se amplía
nuestras espaldas
en particular la nave que está detrás de
nosotros parece aumentar de tamaño a
medida que nos alejamos de ella
hemos sobrepasado el Horizonte como si
nada pero a partir de ahora si
intentamos enviar una señal hacia el
exterior nunca llegará a su destino todo
está destinado a caer hacia el centro
sin esperanza de salir
sin embargo incluso sabiendo que vamos a
morir por el momento todo anda bien es
después de unos 30 segundos justo antes
de alcanzar el centro del agujero negro
que en un abrir y cerrar de ojos
sentimos una fuerza muy poderosa que nos
estira hasta dislocarnos se le llama
espaguetización nuestra cabeza está más
lejos del centro que nuestros pies y la
diferencia de gravedad es tan grande que
muy rápidamente nuestro cuerpo se
desgarra en nuestros últimos momentos
sentimos que tocamos una superficie
plana que ocupa la mitad de nuestro
campo de visión como si cayéramos sobre
un planeta completamente negro mientras
un círculo de luz se intensifica a
nuestro alrededor
los restos triturados de nuestro cuerpo
llegan al centro del agujero negro
nuestro viaje termina aquí por el
momento la física moderna no puede
describir lo que ocurre en las
proximidades del centro de un agujero
negro nuestras teorías actuales
describen singularidades en los que la
curvatura del espacio-tiempo se vuelve
infinita pero los investigadores
sospechan que esta singularidades no
existen realmente y será necesario poder
unificar la gravitación con la física
cuántica Para esperar algún día entender
estas zonas extremas de nuestro universo
algunas hipótesis cuestionan Incluso el
hecho de que podamos sobrevivir tras
cruzar el Horizonte además los agujeros
negros pueden tener una rotación lo que
genera efectos extraordinarios con
múltiples Horizontes en estabilidades
matemáticas cuyas consecuencias aún no
se comprenden
no obstante nuestras teorías actuales
nos permiten tener una buena idea de lo
que veríamos
en particular podemos corregir algunos
conceptos erróneos comunes por ejemplo
el disco que rodea el agujero negro no
es naranja sino azul Si algunas imágenes
no muestran como naranja es porque son
colores artificiales que solamente
buscan representar la luminosidad pero
no el verdadero color que veríamos en la
luz visible también se piensa que vemos
como el tiempo se acelera y la historia
del universo se despliega ante nuestros
ojos a medida que nuestro campo de
visión es gradualmente devorado por el
agujero negro Este es otro concepto
erróneo que no tiene en cuenta el efecto
Doppler ni las aberraciones de la luz
sin embargo aún quedan muchos misterios
por resolver Y Tendremos que seguir
perfeccionando nuestras teorías para
saber qué ocurre realmente en el corazón
de un auténtico agujero negro
[Música]